hillary duff has a surprising reaction
to kids mistaking her for lindsay lohan
it feels very surreal to be honest on
thursday the actress reposted a video
going viral on tick tock on her
instagram story told my students if they
tell me who these people are i would
throw them a pizza party first up a
young hill in character as lizzie
mcguire
oh
[Music]
yeah definitely not lindsay lohan or
debbie ryan who played jessie but the
younger star shouldn't worry because the
kids kept swinging and missing
this is not jojo
not no this is not britney spears but
hillary she's a good sport and even has
a sense of humor about it writing it's
hilary duff
aka lizzy live it learn it floral pants
are back
it's fine really
and get this hillary who's now 34 ended
her post with a dose of honesty quote
man am i happy to not have to be good
for the kids anymore obviously we're in
very different places the mom of three
has been outspoken about her love for
the past but also she wants to embrace
the future case in point the lizzie
mcguire revival series which was
greenlit in 2019 showing lizzy all grown
up i'm so excited for you guys to come
along on this journey with lizzy
and at the time hillary told et how
lizzy 2.0 would be different
she has gained a lot of confidence and
she has a really cool career and you
know she's still
i think she's still going to be faced
with
challenging things where in middle
school those challenging things seemed
funny and simple but relatable at the
time but jumped to 2020 and the show got
scrapped
i think they were really trying to
figure out what kind of content they
want living on disney plus yeah and um
that doesn't totally align with like
where i see lizzy right now you know and
i'm like very protective of her and
they're very protective of her and
though we may not see lizzy again
there's someone in hillary's life who
embraces every part of her past i'll
tell you what banks is obsessed thanks
as my my three-year-old she's obsessed
with my music yeah her daughter is her
number one fan
[Music]
it's very embarrassing to roll through
my neighborhood and she's like yowder
yowder just wants it louder and you'll
do anything to shut up a three-year-old
who repeats herself like she's wasted
and you're just like okay
we're doing it
as for the actress's eldest child her
nine-year-old son luca hill can't wait
to share her latest project with him
hulu's how i met your father
today is the first chapter of my next
great love story i can't wait to like
maybe drink a little bit too much wine
and have him be like you're annoying me
right now get to the chase you know like
that's it's really sweet and hill's
little ones will someday have lots to
enjoy because the sitcom just got picked
up for season two
[Music]
you